i haven't i don't think i've never
stayed in hospital you've never stayed
in a hospital no
i've stayed in a hospital once i'm
trying to remember if i have i
definitely have
it's just it's not a common occurrence
obviously but
i have some time in my childhood i was
taking a weekly trip to the hospital
which is casual it's a free hotel in the
uk if you get injured
have you ever like injured you have you
ever like been to the hospital like
with an injury and stuff like that have
you ever talked about that like you've
injured yourself so bad that you had to
go to the hospital
not like breaking a bone or anything
i've i've never had any bad injuries i
don't think
um no you i had once like i have like
stitches
but you can still kind of see it right
right there on my finger um that was the
only time because like i fell when i was
like two years old
and i landed like kind of like my hands
like that and a piece of glass just went
straight into there so they had to pull
it out and give me stitches but that's
about it really that wasn't boring yeah
that was really funny i was hoping you
i've had some pretty bad injuries but
something i've never had like never been
like i've always been like walking off
or get off
just your arms falling yeah i probably
have like broken my toe or something i'm
just not knowing about
it you know that's pretty common i feel
like it's pretty common i've sprained my
wrist
uh did that um the most boring injury of
all that
let's play my wrist uh yeah yeah it was
from like i think i told this story when
i
failed like a jump ski snowboarding
right and that was [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
yeah i thought i was going to die but i
was like
i'll snowboard it off i'll snowboard i
just kept snowboarding when i was winded
that's how you know we're inside kids
when we haven't like
broken any bones or anything yeah what
are you expecting jerry we're [ __ ]
like i don't know man
you're [ __ ] anime nerds and gamers
i've been very lucky
wanking yourself so hard you dislocate
your wrist or something i don't know i
think about all the injuries i've had
and how i've just
never had any damage from it i'm like
that's very lucky tipped a quad bike
when i was like 10 on myself
and you didn't go to the hospital i
wasn't injured at all jesus hipped a
quad bike on yourself yeah how'd you do
that
i tipped a quad bike so my uh because
you know
my mate owned a farm and i love getting
his house because it's just basically
like a free theme park
yeah and farms are great when you're
yeah because it's like everything's just
a quad bike and he had
a quad bike and his dad didn't give a
[ __ ] he was just like you need to go on
the quad bike right
so just let us go on the quad bike um
and i i i was like uh
one of those like [ __ ] danger addicts
when i was like a 10 year old i just
wanted to like do dangerous things
yeah so uh my friend he was used to
going on the quad bike
and uh he was just like yeah it's all
right just don't go too fast and i was
like all right
immediately went too fast i'm like i was
just turning really really fast
and when i was going so fast the bike
just went like oh
it just flipped over jesus did like a
barrel roll but i i st
so like tip and i think i was small
enough where like i don't i don't know
how it happened but it tipped
yeah i sneaked into the guy i didn't get
hurt at all and i just got up
and the bar was a little [ __ ] on the
thing but we like hit it into place and
it was good and then i went back on it
you went back on it yeah i would not
[ __ ] go back on it
i was like yeah dude that was so fun
let's do it again almost died let's do
it again